einen Startpunkt von wenigstens dreien
scheint heute durchschlagen worden zu
sein Eva Quadbeck ist bei uns
stellvertretende Chefredakteurin vom
redaktionsnetzwerk Deutschland Frau
Quadbeck ist das heute diese whatever
it takes Moment werden die Menschen in
diesem Land nach einem neuen
Entlastungspaket von 200 Milliarden
besser schlafen es ist auf jeden Fall so
ein historischer Moment wie wir ihn auch
in der Finanzkrise erlebt haben als 500
Milliarden erstmal locker gemacht wurden
der corona-krise 600 Milliarden wobei
diese Summen mir erstmal nur ins
Schaufenster gestellt werden mussten
viel übrig geblieben ist ich gehe davon
aus dass diese 200 Milliarden doch
dringend gebraucht werden weil der
Wohlstandsverlust bei den Bürgerinnen
und Bürgern ja schon angekommen ist
ebenso bei den Unternehmen und ich habe
auf diesen Moment eigentlich seit dem 22
juli gewartet das war nämlich der Tag an
dem der Kanzler sein Urlaub unterbrochen
hat nach Berlin gereist ist
Pressekonferenz und wir alle haben
gesagt dass das dieser whatever it
diesem Moment werden wird und dann kam
der Vorschlag der gasumlage die sich ja
dann tatsächlich als überhaupt nicht
umsetzbar herausgestellt hat und dann
eben ist es gerade beschrieben worden
wochenlanger Streit und das Interessante
ist der Finanzminister hat den
Wirtschaftsminister aufgefordert er soll
die Atomkraftwerke länger laufen lassen
und der wiederum hat den Finanzminister
aufgefordert und müssen an die
Schuldenbremse rangehen beide hatten
Recht und beide hatten auch recht in der
Vermutung dass der andere sich jeweils
in seine parteipolitische Wagenburg
verschanzt hatte und das ist jetzt
aufgelöst worden an dem Tag nachdem wir
diesen Anschlag diesen Sabotageakt gegen
die Gaspipelines gesehen haben das heißt
da hat das möglicherweise auch so ein
Moment der Erweckung gegeben hat es
diesen Anschlag auf die Pipelines
gebraucht Katja Gloger ist bei uns
Journalisten Kollegen geschätzt Russland
Kennerin um zu verstehen dass dieser
Krieg den Wladimir Putin führt eben auch
ein Wirtschafts- und ein energiekrieg
ist brauchte es dafür diese Anschläge
vielleicht noch mal das letzte große
Symbol diese Pipelines die also wie ein
Verbindungsstück noch zwischen Russland
und dem Westen auch Deutschland gewesen
sind Symbol ja auch für eine langjährige
sehr erfolgreiche wirtschaftliche
Zusammenarbeit die diese Röhren diese
Linien sind jetzt endgültig gekappt dass
es sich ja noch mal so einen so einen
ein Moment an dem sich alles
konzentriert dass der Krieg in der
Ukraine mit dem was wir in den
vergangenen ein zwei Wochen
nachverfolgen mussten dass der
wahrscheinlich noch lange dauern wird
Monate wenn ich sogar Jahre
dass steht leider auch zu befürchten
bittere Erkenntnis um mit Nuri pur ist
bei uns
Vorsitzender der Grünen Henry pur 200
Milliarden nimmt die ampelregierung
jetzt in die Hand Christian Lindner hat
selber verglichen dass es bei Corona 600
Mill waren und bei der Rettung der
Banken im Jahr 200500 besteht die Gefahr
dass diese 200 Milliarden nicht reichen
werden too late and to little to late
sicher nicht to little wird man sehen
aber es sind ja nicht die einzigen
glänzungen die in die Hand genommen
werden 95 Milliarden sind bereits ja
früher gezielte Entlastungen in drei
Paketen beschlossen worden es gibt auch
andere Gelder die ausgegeben werden 100
Milliarden Sondervermögen für die
Bundeswehr beispielsweise wir haben
jenseits davon und dieser Sommer zeigt
dass das keine Aufschub mehr erträgt
auch 200 Milliarden im Klima und
transformationsschoß aber ausgerechnet
an diese Stelle haben sie ja die Bürger
bis gestern noch belasten wollen mit
dieser gasumlage und jetzt macht die
Regierung einen vollschwenk und fängt an
die Bürger nennenswert zu entlasten
kommt das zu spät und kann es zu wenig
sein die gesamte Sendung darüber
sprechen ob die Umlage sinnvoll war
warum sie sinnvoll war warum sie bei mir
entschuldigen worden ist ich bin dabei
das erwünscht ist aber ich glaube es
macht mehr Sinn jetzt nach vorne zu
schauen und nach vorne geschaut heißt es
die Verstaatlichung von uniper und das
was heute beschlossen worden ist in der
Ampel nämlich dass die drei gaseinkäufer
die es brauchen jetzt auch
maßgeschneiderte Hilfe bekommen ist
jetzt das Retten des Gas liefersystems
in Deutschland und das ist absolut
notwendig weil dann wäre es nicht teurer
geworden der hetzger Gas mehr gegeben
und deshalb ist heute ein großer Schritt
gegangen worden von der Ampel und zwar
von allen und das ist auch gut so gut
jetzt sitzt Christian Lindner neben
ihnen der kurzfristig auch in diese
Sendung zugesagt hat Herr Finanzminister
glauben Sie dass diese 200 Milliarden
ausreichen werden
gesagt dass wir tatsächlich andere
Maßnahmen auch eingeleitet haben denken
Sie an die Bekämpfung der kalten
Progression in der Steuer für die
arbeitende Mitte im nächsten Jahr das
also eine große Summe man muss
hinzufügen dass wir ja alles in unserer
Macht Stehende unternehmen um
zusätzliche Kapazitäten an
Energieerzeugung anders Netz zu bekommen
die Kohle wird zu bekämpfen um die
Preise natürlich zu drücken die Kohle
wird bis 2024 laufen bei der Kernenergie
sind wir noch nicht ganz da wo wir sein
müssten da gibt es noch einen Lizenz ich
bin der Meinung wir müssen jetzt eine
all-in-strategie machen also alle drei
Kernkraftwerke die wir haben während der
ganzen Krise und auch noch die zwei die
gegenwärtig nicht am Netz sind könnte
man reaktivieren hätte man fünf
das wäre also ein zusätzlicher Beitrag
und Preise zu reduzieren und dazu kommt
dann dieser finanzielle Abwehrschirm mit
dem wir ruinöse Person Überforderung von
den Menschen nehmen aber das Preisniveau
wird trotzdem nicht so niedrig sein wie
vor der Krise dass wir im Übrigen auch
ein falsches Signal denn wir wollen ja
auch Gas einsparen und müssen das auch
tun wir sind mit Friedrich Merz heute in
der Runde Herr Merz sie sind als
Opposition jetzt heute um 15 Uhr
offenbar sagt die Agenturen informiert
worden vom Bundeskanzler dass es diese
atomverlängerung war gestern schon
bekannt geben soll dass es die keine
Schuldenbremse geben soll und das ist
ein neuerliches dass die Schuldenbremse
bleibt Entschuldigung und das ist ein
neuerliches Rettungspaket geben soll
wogegen opponiert man noch
informiert worden sind wir über die
Pressekonferenz des Bundeskanzlers und
des Bundesfinanzministers und des
Wirtschaftsministers und danach noch mal
in einer telefonschaltkonferenz die aber
im Grunde genommen die Wiederholung
dessen war was wir aus der
Pressekonferenz schon wussten
wir haben einen Sommer des
missvergnügens dieser Bundesregierung
hinter uns mit einer gasumlage die nun
auch von der Koalition einkassiert war
weil sie wirklich Murks war jetzt hören
wir von 200 Milliarden Euro und einem
doppelwumms ohne dass wir wissen was es
eigentlich genau damit auf sich hat die
Energiepreise gedeckelt zu werden ist
auch unser Vorschlag gewesen aber
Strompreise zu deckeln ist noch mal was
ganz anderes als Gaspreise zu deckeln
und dann kann man nur hoffen dass daraus
nicht Doppel Murks wird denn ich habe
das heute Nachmittag auch gesagt wir
wissen jetzt das Preisschild aber wir
kennen das Produkt nicht wir wissen
nicht was die Koalition jetzt wirklich
will das ist auch sehr kompliziert und
deswegen stehen wir jetzt vor einer
längeren Zeit eines
gesetzgebungsmarathons der stattfinden
muss in den nächsten Wochen und da kann
man nur hoffen dass das handwerklich
besser läuft als in der ersten Runde wir
werden den Finanzminister gleich fragen
ob er uns ein paar mehr Details verrät
außer diesem Preisschild noch mal die
Frage Frau cottbäck wie sehr haben
eigentlich die Menschen im Land mit
ihrer mit ihrem Protest und egal ob es
große Unternehmer oder kleine
Unternehmer oder einfache Privatbürger
waren dafür gesorgt dass die Regierung
handeln musste also haben die Menschen
die Ampel da zum Jagen getragen also der
Druck auf die Ampel ist auf jeden Fall
gewachsen von verschiedenen Seiten
einmal die teils ja auch aggressiven
Proteste wo man dann auch unterscheiden
muss zwischen denen die wirklich aus Not
aus Sorge aus Zweifel zweifelt und
verzweifelt auf die Straße gehen und
jenen die ihr Süppchen darauf kochen und
den Staat einfach delegitimieren wollen
und denen jede Krise Recht ist da muss
man eben differenziert zuschauen aber es
gibt eben eine wachsende Zahl an
Menschen die jetzt entweder an ihre
spartes gehen müssen im Girokonto ins
Defizit reichen rutschen oder überhaupt
ihre Rechnungen nicht mehr bezahlen
können und wenn man eben dann auf die
Umfragewerte der Ampel schaut bei allen
umfrage-instituten sind sie nach unten
gerutscht was auch mit diesem
öffentlichen Streit zu tun hat also man
hat ja dann von Seiten SPD und FDP auch
die Chance genutzt den
Wirtschaftsminister der bislang so
populär war ein Kopf kürzer zu machen
und was ist das Ergebnis die Ampel hat
insgesamt unterm Strich keine eigene
Mehrheit mehr wenn jetzt Bundestagswahl
wäre und dementsprechend groß war der
Druck und ja der wohlverstandsverlust
ist eben schon angekommen im Land das
heißt es gibt nicht nur diesen
politischen Druck sondern es gibt
natürlich auch einen veritablen
ökonomischen Druck damit wir hier bei
der Wirtschaft nicht in den freien Fall
kommen dass das getan wird so noch mal
die Frage Herr Lindner wie viele Briefe
haben sie bekommen in denen Unternehmer
ihnen gesagt haben das ist jetzt nicht
eine Krise das ist und wir haben in dem
und dem und in der Branche eine echte
not uns gegen eine Verzehnfachung der
Energiepreise zu wehren die Frage warum
haben sie sich so viel Zeit gelassen es
ist eigentlich der Einstieg also ich
bin sehr viel unterwegs im Land und habe
auch sehr viel Kontakt zu Handwerk und
Familienunternehmen insofern ist die
Lage im Land und schon sehr klar ich
will aber noch mal diese Interpretation
zurückweisen wir hätten uns viel Zeit
gelassen das führt auf eine falsche
Fährte wir können ja Deutschland mal
vergleichen mit unseren europäischen
Nachbarn und Freunden in der
Europäischen Union schon vor dem
heutigen Tag war das was wir finanziell
mobilisiert haben an Entlastung in
Europa an der Spitze wir haben auch
schon vor dem heutigen Tag die Italiener
die Griechen sie beweisen auf
Großbritannien die neben 150 Milliarden
in die Hand und halten das früher das
war jetzt gerade in großbrit wenn Sie
die volkswirtschaftliche Größenordnung
der entlastungspakete in Deutschland
sehen lade ich Sie ein machen Sie doch
mal den konkreten Vergleich da sind wir
sehr stark unterwegs gewesen aber die
Menschen haben es ja nicht so habe ich
einmal einen Satz zu wissen wir haben
also sehr viel getan aber die Lage
verändert sich natürlich auch wir haben
nordstream 1 plötzlich gar kein Gas mehr
gehabt wir haben bei der Rettung von
uniper oder genauer gesagt um die Kunden
von uniper nicht unversorgt zu lassen
noch eine Kalkulation dass wir 30 40
Prozent aus nordstream 1 bekommen es war
dann Null jetzt die Sabotage ich will
das Wort von dem energiekrieg noch mal
aufnehmen in einem energiekrieg kann man
nicht immer wissen was das Gegenüber
macht und ich kann nur sagen wir machen
nach Kräften das was möglich ist wir
handeln nach bestem Wissen und Gewissen
aber wir haben es auch mit einer
schwersten und
präzedenzlosesten Krise zu tun und zu
glauben wenn ich das aller
Freundlichkeit sagen darf dass
irgendwelche Frage Ergebnisse
irgendjemanden beeinflussen das muss ich
zurückweisen dann geht es darum um die
langfristige Substanz unseres Landes zu
retten mit sehr komplizierten Abwägungen
erlauben sie den Satz noch weil sie
Großbritannien genannt haben
Großbritannien hat auch jetzt wuchtige
Maßnahmen gemacht mit dem Ergebnis dass
das Pfund abgestürzt ist und
Großbritannien Vertrauen am Kapitalmarkt
verloren hat ein zusätzlicher
Wohlstandsverlust viel hilft viel ist
kein guter Rat in einer Inflation da
muss man sehr genau überlegen was man
macht damit man die Situation nicht
verschlechtert dann haben wir den Satz
auch zu Ende gehört und Fragen ihren
Koalitionspartner noch mal Herr noipour
ist diese gasumlage eigentlich nur
erfunden worden um uniper und sefe und
VNG eben nicht aus dem Haushalt und
sofort zu stützen mit einer Kreditierung
durch den Staatshaushalt haben wir über
sechs Wochen eine Umlage diskutiert weil
es eine Finanzierungslücke gab es gab
auch andere Gründe beispielsweise dass
wenn man die Umlage auf die öffentliche
Hand umlegt dass das dazu führt dass die
Kosten auch von denjenigen getragen
werden müssen die zum Beispiel Ölheizung
haben die müssen sowieso weit mehr
zahlen beim Öl teurer geworden ist die
müssen dann Öl bezahlen und Gasheizung
anderer auch das hätte eine
Gerechtigkeit Lücke gehabt diese Weg ist
so entschieden worden ist weil es da zu
dem Zeitpunkt darum ging und das bei
einem extrem aber jetzt haben wir ja
sowieso und Belastung
aber aber quasi ja aber die
Gerechtigkeit die Gerechtigkeit Lücke
ist ja jetzt eine andere und und wir
haben sogar eine extreme Dynamik gehabt
auf dem auf dem Gasmarkt bei den Preisen
und deshalb war nicht klar das war ja
wir haben hier genau in dieser Runde das
ja mal diskutiert das war ja nicht bei
Lufthansa das Lufthansa Carbon gesagt
hat wir haben so so ein Loch dass es so
groß und das muss bitte gestoppt werden
fertig sondern wir haben vor allem
Gaspreise gehabt die in alle Richtungen
ausgeartet sind und es war nicht klar
wie es weitergeht und jetzt ist das
alles eingrenzbarer jetzt haben wir drei
Unternehmen über die wir sprechen jetzt
wird maßgeschneidert dran gehandelt das
ist der Gaspreis weiterhin instabil aber
es die die Ausschläge sind ein bisschen
vorhersehbarer geworden auch deswegen
weil durch den Sabotageakt jetzt klar
geworden ist dass das jetzt die
Markterwartungen natürlich ein bisschen
eingedämmt werden wenn es darum geht was
was Russland nicht das Gefühl dass man
sich diese sechs oder acht Wochen
Diskussionen hätte sparen können und
dass es im übrigen auch das Bild der
Ampel in den Augen der Menschen
verändert hätte ich glaube dass wir
besser werden müssen in der
Synchronisation der Vertrauensgrundlage
in der wir arbeiten besser in der
immunisation
hinter der Bühne funktioniert das auf
der Bühne war es teilweise zu schrill
und da müssen wir alle besser werden
besser aber ich wüsste noch mal sagen
wir haben es mit einem energiekrieg zu
tun
der sich entwickelt wir haben nervöse
Kapital und Energiemärkte und im
Krisenmanagement gibt es keine Blaupause
die man aus der Schublade holt ich will
nicht an die corona-pandemie erinnern wo
eine Vorgänger meine Osterpause gemacht
hat ich glaube man sollte menschliche
Maßstäbe anlegen dass es auch möglich
sein muss dass eine Regierung sich
korrigiert in einer dynamischen Lage ich
sag noch mal man ging davon aus
nordstream 2 nordstream 1 pardon bringt
noch Gas das viel komplett aus und und
eine Kaskade von Ereignissen und da
würde ich immer mich auf jeden
Marktplatz stellen und sagen wir tun was
unserer Macht steht aber es ist auch
eine objektiv schwierige Lage dann
melden sich jetzt trotzdem auch weitere
Kritiker Herr Lindner und sagen die
diese schattenhaus also ein weiterer
Schattenhaushalt oder neben Haushalt
wird gegründet damit sie nicht über
ihren Schatten springen müssen als über
meinen Schatten springe ich schnell
Schuldenbremse ja aber es wird zu der
Eindruck erweckt die Schuldenbremse des
Grundgesetzes sei mein persönlicher
Spleen das steht in der Verfassung und
ich will will schon darauf hinweisen
Milliarde die wir an Schulden aufnehmen
zahlen Sie und zahlen die Zuschauerinnen
und Zuschauer mit Zins und Tilgungen
zurück und ich und die Kinder und
Enkelgeneration ich bin der der
Vermögensverwalter der Bürgerinnen und
Bürger und jede Milliarde Schulden tut
mir weh weil wir zahlen darauf höheren
Zins und aus dem Grund machen wir jetzt
folgendes sie nennen Schattenhaushalt
aber auch da stelle ich mich auf jeden
Marktplatz und in jeder
ökonomenversammlung und begründet das
wir machen den Abwehrschirm das sind
krisenbedingte Kredite die nur
eingesetzt werden zum Beispiel für die
gaspreisbremse
und daneben die Unternehmen oder für
vier Punkte insgesamt exakt aber alles
veranlasst aus der Krise daraus kann man
nicht allgemeine ampelprojekte
finanzieren und hinter diesem
Abwehrschirm da haben wir die privaten
Haushalte wir haben da die Unternehmen
und auch den Staatshaushalt den
Bundeshaushalt für den gilt weiter die
Schuldenbremse und ich will kurz
erklären warum ohne den Abwehrschirm
wäre die Schuldenbremse im nächsten Jahr
nicht zu halten das ist völlig klar ich
möchte aber die Schuldenbremse für den
normalen Staatshaushalt aus zwei Gründen
halten der erste Grund Stichwort
Großbritannien noch einmal hat damit zu
tun dass ich auch den internationalen
Kapitalmärkten signalisieren will
Deutschland ist weiter auf einem
stabilitätskurs wir öffnen nicht alle
Schleusen für alles Mögliche für für
wahlersenkung für Wahlgeschenke für
Subventionen sondern wir sind auf Kurs
und ich macht kein Geheimnis daraus als
Finanzminister habe ich ein ganz
einsamen Job die Länder wollen Geld von
mir meine ressortkollegen wollen Geld
von mir da macht man sich total beliebt
meine eigenen Parteifreunde wollen Geld
und mit der Schuldenbremse habe ich die
Möglichkeit einfach diese Wünsche zu
begrenzen sonst würde es uferlos werden
und deshalb habe ich dieses Verfahren
gewählt an den Führer der Opposition
Herr Merz sie sagen das ist richtig dass
die Schuldenbremse bleibt und trotzdem
die Frage hätte man auf diesen Punkt
dass es in der Schuldenbremse die
Möglichkeit gibt auf eine Notlage auf
eine staatliche Notlage zu verweisen
nicht schon ein bisschen früher aus der
Tasche ziehen können und hätte man nicht
auch schon ein bisschen früher sagen
können wir nehmen jetzt mal ganz viel
Geld in die Hand und was mir damit ganz
konkret machen das überlegen wir uns
klug noch mal die Frage doppelte Frage
der Vergleich mit allen anderen
europäischen Ländern ist insofern etwas
gewagt weil kein anderes europäisches
Land dieses Problem in diesem Umfang hat
wie Deutschland niemand ist so abhängig
gewesen von russischen gab es wie wir
und insofern war die Problemlage bei uns
eine ganz
große der zweite Punkt ist wir haben
eben doch wertvolle Zeit verloren
Deutschland hat Zeit verloren diese
Regierung hat uns Zeit gekostet in dem
Augenblick wo Juniper verstaatlicht
werden sollte war klar dass die
gasumlage nicht mehr geht sie können
nicht einfach staatliches Unternehmen
mit einer umlagefinanzieren so das war
aber in dieser Regierung wochenlang
streitig also wir haben Christian wir
haben nun einen wochenlangen Streit
dieser Regierung erlebt jetzt kann man
aus der Rückschau sagen ich bin damit
einverstanden das ist alles unerprobt
dafür gibt es keine Blaupause da gibt es
keinen Lehrbuch für alles richtig
trotzdem war der Streit überflüssig und
jetzt muss halt auf die Frage stellen
was passiert jetzt diese 200 Milliarden
sind ich sag's noch mal ein Preisschild
für eine Maßnahme oder zwei Maßnahmen
die nicht ausformuliert sind diese
gaspreisbremse ist ein hoches Kommission
ja Expertenkommission das ist auch
richtig dass man da mal Experten
nachfragt denn Gas ist ein weltweit
gehandeltes gut und die Gasmärkte wissen
seit heute in Deutschland kannst du 200
Milliarden Euro geben das wissen die
Gasmärkte seit heute und jetzt wird von
heute an versucht dieses Geld in
Deutschland zu verdienen ohne dass beim
Verbraucher ankommt und wir haben die
Erfahrung wir haben die Erfahrung mit
der tankpreisbremse gemacht da ist auch
nicht alles Geld bei den Verbrauchern
angekommen sondern eine ganze Menge bei
den bei den Unternehmen hängengeblieben
die damit handeln so ich will es nur
sagen da muss die Regierung sehr
aufpassen und das kommt das geht auch
nicht in Deutschland allein ich glaube
nicht dass es eine deutsche Lösung für
dieses Problem gibt sondern es muss eine
europäische Lösung geben für der für den
Strom ist es noch mal etwas anders das
ist ein vielleicht weitgehend regional
handelbares Gut aber ja da will die
Regierung auch Geld einsammeln die Frage
wo dieses Geld hinfließt und wie das neu
verteilt wird ist unbeantwortet
geblieben heute ist aber auch okay kann
man später noch beantworten nur die
Abschöpfung dieser sogenannten
übergewinne will ja auch
gesetzlich sauber abgefasst werden oder
zufallsgewinne und
auch da deswegen noch mal wir kommen
jetzt in ein ziemlich kompliziertes
Gesetzgebungsverfahren und dieser Wurf
muss sitzen das darf jetzt nicht noch
mal so schlecht laufen wie mit der
ich hätte die Reihenfolge anders gewählt
ich hätte gesagt zunächst einmal das ist
die Maßnahme und das ist die Maßnahme
diese
gaspreisbremse ist eine Erfindung von
uns wenn ich mir das mal erlauben darf
in Anspruch zu nehmen das war unser
Vorschlag so etwas zu machen und zwar
auf der Großhandelsebene das Wort
Großhandel steht im Beschluss der
Koalition nicht drin aber da gehört ihre
Erfindung ist jeder umgesetzt es gehört
aber wahrscheinlich dahin das ist alles
nicht so ganz einfach und dann hätte ich
erstmal die Maßnahmen beschlossen und
hätte dann gesagt das könnte jetzt so
viel kosten was jetzt passiert ist
psychologisch ein Problem weil die
Bevölkerung draußen hat das Gefühl okay
es gibt jetzt 200 Milliarden Euro und
jetzt haben wir das Problem gelöst aber
wir sind weit entfernt davon das Problem
zu lösen das darf auch nicht der
Eindruck entstehen als dass wir jetzt
nicht mehr einsparen müssen wir haben in
diesem Jahr mehr Gas verstromt und
verbraucht als im letzten Jahr dieser
Eindruck der den muss die
Bundesregierung auch an jeder Stelle
widersprechen dass wir jetzt sozusagen
alles gelöst haben wenn sie am Anfang
ganz am Anfang der Lösung des Problems
wenn Sie Herr März Kanzler wären dann
hätten wir schon seit März auf
russisches Gas versorgt das habe ich nie
gesagt das wird immer wieder behauptet
ich habe gesagt nordstream 1 könnte man
vom Netz nehmen wenn man andere
Bezugsquellen hat es gibt ja noch zwei
drei weitere Bezugsquellen die wir haben
die auch zum Teil durch die Ukraine
laufen ich habe nie mir die auch von
einigen Kollegen vertretene Meinung zu
eigen gemacht wir sollten nein das ist
ihre Pressekonferenz wollen wir nochmal
reinhören wir müssen es aber vollständig
senden und nicht nur zur Hälfte mit dem
Einsatz ich bin gespannt was sie sind
bin ich auch dann mal los
deswegen ist unserer Vorschlag ist
unsere bitte unsere Forderung auch an
die Bundesregierung keinen weiteren
Bezug von Gas aus der Pipeline Nord
Stream 1 so und da haben sie aber den
zweiten Teil meines Satzes ist genau
meine Befürchtung gewesen abgeschnitten
der la lautete vorausgesetzt es gibt
genügend Gas aus anderen bezugsfällen
die wir auch aus Russland noch beziehen
können so dann werden wir das noch mal
überprüfen sie haben aber auch in dem
gleichen Statement gesagt wir sind der
Meinung dass es jetzt an der Zeit ist
auch einen weiteren Schritt zu gehen und
zwar auch den weiteren Gasbezug aus der
Pipeline Nord Stream 1 zu starten
haben Vorschlag und bitte und Forderung
an die Bundeswehr genau und dann habe
ich gesagt vorausgesetzt es gibt
genügend Bezugsquellen auch aus anderen
gasgrillen ich habe nie mir die es gibt
gab Kollegen in der Bundeshausfraktion
die das so gesehen haben ich war nicht
meine Meinung auch nicht die Meinung der
Mehrheit sondern es ging um nordstream 1
und 2 aber nicht um andere Quellen aber
sie haben Vorschlag machen also ich weiß
nicht wie es Zuschauerinnen und
Zuschauern geht aber für mich ist die
Sendung ein bisschen sehr viel
Rückspiegel das ist jetzt auch bei
Friedrich Merz und deshalb würde ich
gerne Blick nach vorne weiter riechen
ist eine Sache neu und klar es wird seit
dem gestrigen Tag offensichtlich keine
Möglichkeit mehr geben einen Weg zurück
zu machen zu ermöglichen dass
Deutschland noch mal in den Besitz von
russischem Gas kommt und wenn Sie das
gestatten
um zu sagen ist uns das bewusst dass es
diese Rückzugsmöglichkeit nicht mehr
gibt es ist also auch ein wir werden
irgendwann mal wieder russisches Gas
haben
dass sie nicht mehr aufhören Kubicki
reagieren müssen weil das die Vorschläge
sicher ich verwende wenn es um die
internationale Politik geht ungern das
Wort nie wieder das eine Lehre der
deutschen Geschichte weil auch nach der
Zeit des Nationalsozialismus sind wir in
die internationale Staatengemeinschaft
irgendwann zurückgekehrt also bei nie
wieder bin ich vorsichtig aber dennoch
hat
ich möchte eigentlich heute niemanden
kritisieren sondern nur in der Sache mal
ein Gedanken einbringen in Anschluss an
das was Friedrich Merz gesagt hat denn
er hat Recht gaspreisbremse ist alles
andere als einfach und deshalb muss man
sie international einbetten das erste
was wir tun ist dass wir international
Bezugsquellen finden von Flüssiggas ich
sag mal so es ist endlich um das auch
unsere Kolleginnen und Kollegen von
Bündnis 90 die Grünen langfristige
Verträge abschließen das ja man das ist
ja nicht trivial ihr wollt eigentlich
raus aus dem Gas und jetzt müssen wir
langfristige Verträge schließen weil nur
mit langfristigen Verträgen kriegt man
günstige Preise und das zweite ich bin
der Meinung ja wie Sie wissen als
Liberaler man muss Märkte wirken lassen
oder man muss ganz hart und ganz
konsequent in Märkte reingehen ich finde
diese mittleren Positionen nicht richtig
entweder vertraust du auf den Markt oder
du hast eine Ausnahmesituation und gehst
dann mit der gesamten staatlichen Macht
rein warum sage ich das mit Blick auf
den Gasmarkt wir sollten überlegen
europäisch einheitlich international
aufzutreten und wir sollten diskutieren
eine kapung beim Importpreis für Gas das
muss auf dem Weltmarkt funktionieren das
heißt der Vorschlag wäre es muss spürbar
oberhalb des Weltmarktpreises für
Flüssiggas in Asien liegen damit die
Tanker die zu uns fahren nicht umdrehen
nach Asien aber wenn Europa insgesamt
sagt wir führen nur noch mit diesem
Aufschlag ein hat das auf den
Weltmärkten direkt für uns ein
dämpfendes Niveau und das würde ich
gerne auch auf der europäischen Ebene
diskutieren wenn wir das als 27 machen
hat das eine Chance auf Umsetzung die
energieministerkonferenz aber die
Wahrscheinlichkeit dass die einfach nur
im Streit auseinander gehen ist relativ
hoch also da bisher ist es ja noch
niemals gelungen beim Strompreis das zu
machen was eigentlich offensichtlich ist
nämlich die Gewinnabschöpfung also auch
da kommt man nicht zusammen deshalb ist
ist natürlich sehr schwierig darauf zu
setzen und den Vorschlag gegen
europaweit einzukaufen den hat es von
Mario Draghi im Europäischen Rat vor
einigen Monaten schon gegeben und der
ist von Deutschland und Frankreich
abgelehnt worden also ich bin gespannt
was dabei herauskommt das ist ein das
ist eine Operation am offenen Herzen
ohne Narkose genau und deswegen ist es
ja nicht ganz sauber wenn man dann sagt
warum habt ihr kein Handbuch vorgelegt
und das kann doch einfach abgearbeitet
genau es gibt kein und deshalb ist es ja
richtig was dass man auf Sicht fliegen
muss und dass man sich auch korrigieren
muss sie haben den zeitassberg gerade
genannt der ist völlig richtig weil
alles was wir machen wollen ist ja unter
immensen Zeitdruck dafür gibt es Gründe
die Krisenfestigkeit dieses Landes ist
nicht gewährleistet früher geworden in
den letzten Jahren ist es richtig man
sollte nicht immer über die letzten
Jahre reden es ist korrekt aber genau
deswegen und das ist der einzige Dissens
der mir hier haben neben der Atomfrage
ist aus unserer Sicht weil man die
Zeiten mit der dieser großen
Beschleunigung versehen muss dass wir
glauben dass und die Schuldenbremse
anders anpacken muss und zwar fürs
nächste Jahr unter dem Strich aber haben
wir heute als Koalition gezeigt dass wir
dass wir Lösungen liefern da haben wir
uns auf den Tisch so und jetzt sind wir
bei Ihnen beiden und wenn Sie es
schaffen wäre es toll dass auch
irgendwie so konkret wie möglich zu
sagen nämlich die Frage zu beantworten
jeder Bürger dieses Landes denkt jetzt
welcher Teil von diesen 200 Milliarden
ist für mich und hilft mir diese
zufallspreissteigerungen in
Anführungsstrichen also die
Preissteigerungen in der Energie egal ob
Strom oder Gas oder Öl
abzufedern hoffen Sie auch auf einer
europäische Lösung Herr Noriko also ist
das auch ihre Forscher oder sagen Sie
wie kriegen diese Geschichte diese 200
Milliarden in vier Wochen durch und dann
schaffen wir in den vier Wochen zu
entwerfen wie sowohl dieser
gaspreisdeckel in Deutschland aussieht
als auch der strompreisdeckel das ist ja
Teil der Vereinbarung dass wir
doppelgleisig fahren und dass wir
versuchen europäisch das alles
hinzubekommen und beginnen mit dem Strom
das haben wir ja beim Koalition
Ausschuss beim dritten entlassungspaket
ja schon vereinbart und gleichzeitig
natürlich alles vorbereiten damit wir
können Sie heute kann Herr Lindner kann
Herr nuripur den Menschen an diesem
Bildschirmen heute sagen wie hoch diese
Entlastung sein wird wenn es eine Vers 6
oder für siebenfachung des Gaspreises
gibt und wenn es hier und da eine
verneuen und Verzehnfachung des
Strompreises gibt
dann haben sie irgendwann eine
Kalkulation für die 200 Milliarden
gemacht die diese Zahl muss ja irgendwie
zustande gekommen das geht ja darum dass
also was wir sagen kann ist dass wir
natürlich beim Grundbedarf denn den
Leuten beistehen damit der Grundbedarf
ist natürlich jeweils unterschiedlich
aber weil wir auch die Unternehmen
beispielsweise drin haben in diesen in
diesen 200 Milliarden aber dass der
Grundbedarf finanziert
sozusagen gedeckelt ist und unten in der
Bremse hatte ihren Preis und alles
darüber natürlich den Anreizen zu sparen
nicht entzogen also ich bin dankbar dass
wir über die die sachpunkte die kommen
jetzt auch genau sprechen können wir
haben zum einen die strompreisbremse bei
der strompreisbremse wollen wir die
zufallsgewinne wegnehmen zufallsgewinne
entstehen wenn der Produzent von
Kohlestrom oder Windstrom so bezahlt
wird als hätte er Gas eingekauft das
wollen wir abschöpfen und die damit
gewonnenen Milliarden wollen wir im
System Strom lassen und dort die
Verbraucherinnen und Verbraucher und die
Betriebe entlasten beim Strom das ist in
Europa auch vorgesehen wenn es in Europa
nicht gelingt machen wird national ist
keine Steuer es bleibt also im System
Stromkunde
wir werden möglicherweise auch aus den
200 Milliarden noch zusätzlich Geld in
den Strommarkt geben eigentlich war das
nicht verabredet aber es kann sein dass
die sogenannten zufallsgewinne nicht
ausreichen um auch bei den gewerblichen
Verbrauchern eine hinreichende
Entlastung zu organisieren und dann
haben wir daneben die gaspreisbremse
Friedrich Merz hat völlig recht mit
seinem Wort das ist eine Operation
Betroffenen Herzen ohne Narkose sehr
komplexer Markt viel hängt zusammen
subventioniert man das runter wie die
Spanier hat man das Phänomen das
plötzlich die Gaskraftwerke mehr Strom
produzieren und der günstige Strom mit
knappen Gas produziert wird dann ins
Ausland exportiert und deshalb haben wir
also sehr kommt das war jetzt nur ein
komplizierter Aspekt deshalb haben wir
eine
Kommission eingerichtet mit Experten aus
der Wirtschaft der Wissenschaft
Praktikum es sind auch
verbraucherschützerinnen und
Verbraucherschützer dabei
Wohnungswirtschaft und andere und die
machen jetzt sehr zeitnah ich würde mal
sagen deutlich anfangen Oktober eine
Konzeption und das werden wir dann
parlamentarisch beraten und umsetzen
also
man werden es die Leute mit ihren
Rechnungen merken bei ihren Rechnungen
also wann kommen die ersten Rechnungen
die dann weniger hoch sind also so
schnell wie möglich ja sie lächeln aber
ich will jetzt keine Frist nennen weil
ich bin selber noch nicht mal zuständig
wenn ich jetzt dem Kollegen Robert
Habeck öffentliche eine Frist setzen
würde bis wann er aus umgesetzt dann
wird Eva quadbecken Leitartikel machen
der Lindner hat jetzt wieder versucht
dem Harbeck und deshalb sage ich nur so
schnell wie möglich gut und noch mal
zurück zu der anderen Frage in welcher
Größenordnung werden die Bürger dieses
Landes entlastet reden wir über 50
Prozent absenken jetzt dieser
zusätzlichen Kosten oder schaffen sie 60
Prozent
minimieren dämpfen diese zusätzlichen
das hängt auch von der Entwicklung der
Weltmarktpreise ab das hängt von den
europäischen Lösungen ab Stichwort
preiskappung und das hängt auch davon ab
unsere politischen Entscheidungen wie
schnell kommen
Kohlekraftwerke wie schnell kommen
lng-terminals ans Netz kann dir nicht
ersparen wie schnell kommt Kernen
Ergebnisse
für ein Gasmarkt zumindest den
nationalen Vorschläge werden wir bis
Mitte Oktober haben und dann wird das
Kabinett sehr schnell beraten und dann
sehr schnell ins parlamentarische
Verfahren gehen und wir wissen dass der
Bundestag sehr schnell entscheiden kann
und dafür gibt es den breiten Willen und
dementsprechend gehe ich davon aus dass
es keine Frage ist von Monaten sondern
der nächsten Woche ja also nur um es
nochmal deutlich zu machen sie schicken
ja jetzt gerade mit einem Vorlauf von
sechs Wochen deshalb gab es die
Erfindung der gasumlage den Menschen
nach Hause dass sie etwas zusätzlich
bezahlen sollen deshalb wollen sie
glaube ich jetzt sehr gerne wissen wie
hoch die Entlastung wäre die Sie sich
stattdessen gewünscht haben
wird die wieder zurückgezahlt für die
Menschen die schon in ihren Post haben
aber manche Briefe kommen
riesige Arbeit und Kosten gehabt mit
diesen blödsinnigen Briefen die da jetzt
geschickt worden sind aber das Kabinett
scheint im Umlaufverfahren
wirklich jedenfalls finde wenn ich das
richtig verstehe
die Umlage wird zum ersten Oktober nicht
kommen die Leute haben sie nicht bezahlt
brauchen Sie nicht bezahlen und die
Stadtwerke werden auch sehr schnell
informieren und die werden gerade
wiederum informiert damit sie gescheit
informieren
da nicht irgendwo
das ist doch nun wirklich also da darf
man doch mal drüber lachen wie sie da
gemacht haben wenn ich das jetzt mal
schreiben darf das ist eine Operation an
einem offenen Herzen ohne Narkose das
sind meine Worte so da ist die fast
große brüderliche Umarmung wir werden
und müssen parallel dazu darüber reden
welche Situation wir ab morgen
gefühlt eben auch schon seit gestern in
Moskau haben die putin-regierung hat
beschlossen vier oblastie viel Regionen
im Süden und Osten der Ukraine
formal zu annektieren
und hat pseudo-referenten dort
stattfinden lassen und das ist die
Situation mit der wir
konfrontiert sind
ich denke dass der russische Präsident
und das russische Volk die Entscheidung
treffen und uns in Russland aufnehmen
werden
kein Wunder
Wahlhelfer waren mit schwer bewaffneter
Eskorte durch die Häuser gezogen
geflohene Ukrainer berichten von
unmissverständlichen Drohungen
am 23 September haben sie angefangen sie
sind von Haus zu Haus gegangen und haben
gefragt wollt ihr abstimmen oder nicht
wenn ihr nicht dafür seid werden wir
ganz anders mit euch umgehen
putin will schon morgen die Annexion der
Gebiete luhansk Don jetzt
saporicia und rason verkünden
die kremlogik versucht die Ukraine diese
Regionen zurückzuerobern
sei dies ein Angriff auf Russland
Ex-Präsident Dimitri mitwireddev droht
unverhohlen russland hat das Recht wenn
nötig Atomwaffen einzusetzen
dies sei sicherlich kein Bluff
wir sind bei Katja Gloger und der Frage
was wird sich ändern ab dem morgigen Tag
weitere Eskalation in der Ukraine ein
Krieg der noch viel länger dauern wird
als wir es uns in unseren schlimmsten
Träumen eigentlich nicht vorstellen
konnten
die
Annexion dieser vier Gebiete gibt Putin
Zeit er kann einen Erfolg verkünden
nicht den Sieg den er haben wollte nach
drei Tagen Siegesparade in Kiew so wie
es ursprünglich ja angedacht gewesen ist
aber immerhin ein Erfolg holt Gebiete
ins russische Reich Schutz der Menschen
vor dem schlimmen Westen und den
staatsstreichlern und Faschisten in Kiew
so wie man das ja in Russland sieht
damit verschaffte sich innenpolitisch
Spielraum auch in der Legitimation
dieser teilmobil machen dieser
vermeintlichen Immobilie machen die in
Wahrheit sehr viel mehr ist als eine
Teilmobilmachung
und
er zieht den besten gegenüber
eben eine rote Linie die er selbst aber
bestimmt denn er wird nach der Annexion
dieser Gebiete entscheiden können
welche Form sagen der der der
militärischen Reaktion des Westens eher
nun als Angriff werden auf Russland
Souveränität und territoriale Integrität
und damit verschafft er sich ein
Eskalationspotenzial mit dem wir umgehen
müssen und offensichtlich
hat es die Amerikaner dem nationalen
Sicherheitsberater des US-Präsidenten
dann doch so sehr in Sorge versetzt dass
er sich entschieden hat in die
Öffentlichkeit zu gehen
mit der Information dass man Russland
informiert habe und gewarnt habe und
trainiert habe darüber wie der Westen
reagieren würde sollte Russland
Atomwaffen einsetzen es wäre also
gewöhnlich harte Reaktionen
außergewöhnlich starke nicht gekannte
Konsequenzen absolut wir wissen nicht
welche es sind aber das die Welt mit dem
Mord mit der Morgen vollzogenen
Angliederung an die Russische Föderation
eines großen Teil des ukrainischen
Staatsgebietes wir reden von 15 Prozent
immerhin dass die Welt damit noch
unsicherer geworden ist ist leider wahr
und da müssen wir umgehen auch hier in
Deutschland putinen erpresst uns nuklear
de facto und wir müssen mit diesem Fakt
umgehen dürfen uns gleichzeitig aber
nicht abschrecken lassen davon wir sind
bei der Politik Friedrich Merz
Situation ist eine noch gefährlichere
und wir machen jetzt einfach weiter wie
bisher
sagen wir den Ukrainern also bis zu
Demarkationslinie vom 24.2 dürft ihr
schießen und nicht weiter weil sonst
kann Putin sagen ihr seid auf russischem
Territorien diese Linie ist ja nicht
identisch mit den Gebieten die er jetzt
vereinnahmt also wie reagiert der Westen
der Westen muss unverändert mit
Entschlossenheit und Klarheit reagieren
abgestimmt auch international und meine
persönliche Meinung ist die man hätte
vielleicht der Ukraine noch mehr helfen
können ich meine sogar müssen um die
Aussichtslosigkeit für die russische
Seite noch einmal zu unterstreichen
Russland kann diesen Krieg nicht
gewinnen
die Ukraine muss in die Lage versetzt
werden dieser völkerrechtswidrigen
Annexion auch entgegenzutreten und
wir dürfen nicht aufgeben darauf zu
hoffen dass es dann irgendwann eine
diplomatische Lösung gibt aber die wird
es erst geben wenn die
Aussichtslosigkeit für Russland klar ist
und diese Aussichtslosigkeit ist haben
jetzt noch nicht und sie ist vielleicht
so lange nicht da so lange Putin an der
Macht ist Frage an Herrn noripour sie
sind auch aus dem Politiker in ihrer
Partei und dafür bekannt macht der
Westen einfach weiter so obwohl es diese
Eskalation gibt und Putin sich eine in
Anführungsstrichen legitim Legitimation
baut um zu sagen der Westen führt gegen
russlandkrieg ich will voranstellen dass
man natürlich sehr ernst nehmen muss was
das Moskau kommt aber das gesamte System
basiert nach innen wie nach außen auf
Angst und wenn wir uns von dieser Angst
lähmen lassen dann hat Putin gewonnen
und zwar weit über die Ukraine hinaus
und das können uns einfach nicht leisten
und deshalb gilt es dass wir den
Beistand für die Ukraine bringen wo es
angebracht ist und wo wir es hinkriegen
und wo es sinnvoll ist und wir haben
jetzt völlig zu Recht gesagt hat
international abgestimmt und
dementsprechend gilt es dass man jeden
Tag in der Regierung und bei uns in der
Bundesregierung genauso wie bei anderen
Mitgliedstaaten schaut was geht es geht
nicht und deshalb zu russischen
Territorium das heißt es ist morgen der
vorwurz nunmal nicht russisches
Territorium und wenn er morgen erklärt
der Hafen von oder die die Bucht von
Kiel ist russisches Territorium dann
wäre sie auch irrelevant für uns und
dementsprechend gilt es dass wir der
Ukraine beistehen mit mit dem was was
uns möglich ist und
bevor jetzt die Debatte wieder immer in
dieselbe Ecke kommt wir können über
einzelne Waffensysteme diskutieren aber
ich glaube das ist nicht die zentrale
Frage die zentrale Frage ist was geht
und was geht nicht und alle in dieser
Regierung arbeiten jeden Tag daran damit
jeden Tag von neuem entschieden werden
kann was jeweils passend geht und was
nicht geht ich würde nicht sagen
Panzerhaubitze eskalieren nicht
Kampfpanzer schon das ist eine
bemerkenswerte Argumentation der ich
nicht folgen kann aber wir ja hier viel
und die Bestände der Bundeswehr sind
nicht tabu weil weil die helfen auch
unsere Sicherheit wenn die dann auch
nicht die der Industrie aber natürlich
müssen wir uns international abstimmen
und das ist das Thema so und dann frage
ich bevor ich ein Linder Frage noch mal
Frau Quadbeck gleiche Frage können wenn
sich die Situation wenn sich die
Situation in der Ukraine so verschärft
wie sie ist jetzt tut eine atomare
Drohung im Raum steht wie sie es
offensichtlich so noch nicht gestanden
hat können wir dann einfach so
weitermachen wie bisher wir brauchen auf
jeden Fall mehr Mut und mehr Kraft
weiterzumachen aber das ist eine
Situation in der es eigentlich keinen
Weg zurückgibt also wir können auch
nicht von unserer Linie zurück dass wir
sagen wir stehen an der Seite der
Ukraine weil das würde Putin ja
ermutigen den nächsten Schritt zu gehen
und sofort wieder weiter in die Ukraine
reinzugehen wenn wir eben diese Art von
Angst zeigen nichtsdestotrotz
muss man in dem Sinne vorsichtig bleiben
dass man nicht so naiv sein darf zu
glauben wenn man jetzt vielleicht noch
mal 100 Panzer in die Ukraine schickt
dann werden die das Ding gewinnen und
das alles rum das wird nicht schnell
gehen das ist auch meine Einschätzung
dass es eher sehr lange dauert das heißt
wir müssen uns darauf anstellen einen
langen Atem zu haben und die
ampelregierung steht vor der großen
Herausforderung auch die Menschen hier
im Land mitzunehmen alle europäischen
Länder stehen vor der großen
Herausforderung ihre Bevölkerung
mitzunehmen und das ist eben auch nicht
so einfach weil sich ja weil wir eben
inzwischen in diesem Krieg mit drin
stecken und die Auswirkungen bemerken
der Spiegel hat ja absoluter
Drahtseilakt der
den wir gehen müssen jetzt denn Russland
muss scheitern in der Ukraine also sonst
wäre es ein Präzedenzfall der nicht nur
europäische sondern auch am Ende globale
Sicherheit und mir richtig bedroht man
denkt mal irgendwie China als Atommacht
und und Begehren in Taiwan also er muss
scheitern in der Ukraine und zugleich
aber
müssen wir
beachten dass es ein eskalationsrisiko
gibt und deswegen irgendwie die
Geschlossenheit die die Abstimmung die
Gemeinsamkeit des Westens die glaube ich
kann man gar nicht irgendwie höher
halten und das ist als man als es als es
sein muss und
das ist wahnsinnig schwer zu
organisieren weil es auch eine wachsende
Zahl von Menschen gibt die sich fragen
ist das das richtige was wir tun und
eskalieren wir nicht indem wir immer
mehr Waffen dahin geben der
Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz so schreibt
der Spiegel soll in einer Unterredung
gesagt haben dass 30 Prozent der
Menschen und damit irrt er sicherlich
nicht sich die Frage stellen ob es gut
ist sowohl Sanktionen als auch
Waffenlieferungen so durchzuziehen wie
wir das tun Putin spekuliert darauf dass
unser Atem nicht lang genug ist
wird das Kalkül von Wladimir Putin
aufgehen wie groß ist ihre Sorge Herr
Lindner nein das Kalkül kann und darf
nicht aufgehen ich stimme Ihnen voll zu
das wäre ein Risiko für die globale
Sicherheit es wäre aber auch ein
Desaster für die Werte des Multi
lateralismus und der liberalen
Demokratien also in der Ukraine wird
auch das verteidigt was uns als
Gesellschaft heilig sein muss deshalb
muss jeden Tag geprüft werden was können
wir zusätzlich tun um die Ukraine in
diesem Kampf um Selbstbestimmung zu
unterstützen und zugleich ich bin ganz
bei Ihnen es gibt eskalationspotenziale
und deshalb empfiehlt es sich gerade
auch Deutschland alles
ängstens abzustimmen mit unseren
Verbündeten und Partnern insbesondere
auch den USA bin jetzt die Drohung mit
Nuklearwaffen erneut im Raum steht dann
ist das eine Frage die auch innerhalb
der NATO besprochen werden muss klar
jedenfalls ist ich glaube da stimmen wir
hier am Tisch überein und auch in der
Staatengemeinschaft diese Annektion
diese referen können nicht anerkannt
werden das ist Show da wird eine Kulisse
aufgebaut die rechtlich keine Bedeutung
hat wir haben nach den Sanktionen noch
nicht gefragt tenoritur das ist hier
vielleicht ein guter Punkt auch nach dem
was eben an diesen
pipelinesentschuldigung da passiert ist
die das sind insgesamt vier Explosionen
gewesen ob es noch mehr gibt wissen wir
nicht offensichtlich will ja und das ist
jetzt noch nicht zu klären
uns Putin damit ein Signal setzen wenn
oder ein Signal geben keine Ahnung wenn
man davon ausgeht dass es tatsächlich
aus Moskauer richtigen kommt welchen
reiben machen Sie sich darauf glauben
Sie dass es gelingen wird überhaupt
irgendwann zu ermitteln wer das tat
diese Anschläge ich glaube dass die
politischen Zeichen aber auch die
Plausibilitäten mehr als deutlich sind
ich glaube dass es
das heißt dass ich davon ausgehe dass
auch deswegen ich meine man kann sich ja
gar nicht mal wie groß das ist die die
Gasblase ist 700 Meter breit die die wir
da gerade sehen ja der das muss 500
Kilogramm TNT hat Christian Linda vorhin
auch nochmal angesprochen das ist
gewaltig was da was da gerade passiert
ist das ist staatlich gesteuert und
es gibt nicht besonders viele Staaten
die das können gerade in der Ostsee
kommt nur Russland in frage ich gehe
davon aus dass das ein weiterer Baustein
ist neben der dieser
scheinreferentin dass die Europäische
Union sehr bald ein weiteres
Sanktionspaket wird Schnüren müssen ein
weiteres Sanktionspaket gegen Putin
Schnüren müssen welchen reiben Herr
Lindner machen Sie sich darauf die CIA
warnte im Sommer dieses Jahres davor
dass es solche Anschläge geben könnte
hat der Westen das nicht ernst genug
genommen es ist in der Bundesregierung
diskutiert worden
wir sehen jetzt das
an Gesichts der der Referenten und der
Kriegsführung das Putin skrupellos ist
bei den
Sabotageakten
verbietet es sich mir jetzt öffentlich
zu spekulieren solange es keine klaren
Nachweise gibt klar ist die Lage hat
sich insgesamt verschärft und man kann
gegenwärtig sich
nicht darauf verlassen dass jetzt eine
Stabilität erreicht ist sondern weitere
Eskalationen sind immer möglich
Putin hat sehr lange schon auch Form der
hybriden Kriegsführung angewandt dazu
gehört auch Desinformation in unseren
Gesellschaften ist eine ganz große
Problematik was ich so an an
WhatsApp-Nachrichten bekomme mit kleinen
Videos von von Bekannten oder von
Bürgerinnen und Bürgern die meine Nummer
haben wo ich dann sage oh das ist zwar
sehr professionell gemacht aber das ist
jetzt nicht das ist nicht zdf-qualität
sondern es ist sondern es ist eine
Intention dahinter zu destabilisieren
also Angriffe auf Infrastruktur
Cyberangriffe
Propaganda Desinformation das gehört zum
Repertoire von Putin da kann man sie
auch nur an die Bürgerinnen und Bürger
wenden und sagen man muss genau
überlegen was ist das für eine
Informationsquelle die ich auf Facebook
da auf Tour ist das eigentlich wirklich
real oder soll ich in einer Weise
glauben gemacht werden es sei real um
auch vielleicht die eigene Gesellschaft
zu destabilisieren Herr Merz muss jetzt
noch mal sich ganz kurz anhören was wir
apropos
Opposition von ihnen in der letzten
Woche gehört haben